vous souvenez vous de la première fois
où vous avez nager tout seul vous
souvenez vous de la première fois où
vous avez fait du vélo tout seul laisser
remonter à la surface cette ce sentiment
cette émotion à découvrir que
l'impossible est devenu possible
les êtres humains sont nés explorateurs
cet instinct de dépasser les limites ça
fait partie de ce que nous sommes
nos rêves notre imagination nous pousse
constamment à dépasser les limites à
explorer l'inconnue c'est propre à
chaque individu mais c'est vrai aussi
pour l'humanité toute entière et les
grandes ce exploration de nos
prédécesseurs s'étaient pas des chemins
faciles a exigé beaucoup de ténacité et
de courage de conviction mais les
conquêtes qui en ont résulté ses
conquêtes elles ont marqué profondément
notre histoire ses conquêtes
elles sont encore aujourd'hui des
éléments majeurs de notre civilisation
lors de la même façon vis-à-vis des
générations futures
notre génération a le devoir d'ouvrir
des voies qui seront certaines des
solutions essentielles à l'avenir dans
les frontières on les as de repousser
mais les rêves d'exploration de
découverte
il reste intacte et moi j'ai un rêve et
j'aimerais la partager au bout
je rêve d'aller sur la lune
plus encore je rêve de participer à la
construction d'un village lunaire le
money village alors se rêve en gelée
dans la tête depuis juillet 69
j'avais 12 ans à l'époque le premier pas
de l'homme sur la lune
cette nuit là j'ai eu le sentiment que
c'était possible que cette aventure elle
pouvait être la mienne je lis pas
complètement réalisé ce rêve mais je
m'en suis quand même beaucoup approché
je suis une grande privilégié d'avoir pu
aller jusqu'à la station mir et la
station spatiale internationale
aujourd'hui la lune je la rave habité de
façon permanente occupé par un équipage
dans ce village sur la lune cette lune
elle est dans les faubourgs de notre
terre c'est vrai quand on parle des
espaces les distancer par des ordres de
grandeur un peu troublant ch vous
rappelle la lune elle est à 380 mille
kilomètres de la terre le voyage pour y
accéder ça peut paraître trois jours
quatre jours la station spatiale
internationale c'est une orbite à 400 km
de la terre et nous atteignons cette
orbite en moins de neuf minutes
quant à la planète mars alors à il
s'agit de distance de 55 à 400 millions
de kilomètres et le voyage dont les
conditions actuelles prendra à peu près
six mois
la lune c'est notre histoire
elle est de toutes les cosmogonies de
nos mythes ancestraux
vous imaginez tous les loups garous les
sorcières en pleine lune les de nos
mythes contemporains l'influencent de la
lune sur l'humeur des femmes ou le
jardinage
même la bio agriculture aujourd'hui la
lune c'est notre culture
les poètes long millions rim les auteurs
de science-fiction l'on exploré les
cinéastes l'ont rêvé les astronomes les
géophysiciens ont eu de longues
discussions sur une lune fille soeur
cousine de la terre alors les agences
spatiales
ils sont allés s'en sont approchés et 6
ont même posé ya toujours d'ailleurs des
robots à la surface de la lune et jamais
mis des hommes alors que ce qui s'y
intéressent en a parlé de la lune
puisque nous y sommes déjà allés
oui la lune nous l'avons
visiter mais nous n'y avons jamais vécu
ça c'est la durée du plus long séjour
sur la surface lunaire
c'était apollo 17 décembre 72 gène
cernan et harrison schmitt son essai un
petit peu plus de trois jours sur la
surface lunaire
vous conviendrez avec moi qu'il ya une
grande différence entre un endroit que
l'on visite est un lieu que l'on habite
ce rêve là ce rêve de l'enfance
il est toujours très très plaisant pour
moi comme en janvier 69
alors quand j'étais enfant on
j'imaginais la lune peuple et c'était
mes lectures peuplé de l'union c'est et
lucien de samosate ou peuplé de
sélénites c'était cyrano de bergerac
bon aujourd'hui je l'imaginent cette
lune habité par des humains et ce rêve
lors vivre sur la lune dans un village
on vous l'avez compris c'est un rêve un
petit peu personnelle mais je ne suis
pas la seule elle portait beaucoup s'y
est ce si je travaille aujourd'hui à l'
agence spatiale européenne jugée
responsable d'un groupe interne
on est en train de mobiliser nos
énergies
parce que c'est un rêve qui se construit
avec toutes ces ses volontés et l'europe
l'europe elle peut et l'europe elle doit
être un catalyseur qui permettra à ce
projet de se réaliser
ce projet là si je vous en parle
aujourd'hui c'est parce que j'ai envie
que bientôt il soit aussi dans vos rêves
dans vos désirs dans vos esprits
ce projet l'un si j'en parle aujourd'hui
c'est parce que je souhaite qu'il fasse
partie des choix de nos gouvernants des
choix de nos responsables européens en
particulier parce que ces responsables
européens ils seront heureux de voir
cette adhésion impatients de la jeunesse
européenne portée par des projets
collectifs d'avenir parce que ces
responsables européens ils seront fiers
de voir que l'europe peut être un acteur
majeur dans ses prochains pas de notre
civilisation
d'autres y seront l'europe doit
participer à cette aventure du 21e
siècle
elle ne peut pas en être absente ce
projet là c'est un projet de
civilisation c'est un projet de société
c'est je dis souvent un banc d'essai
pour le futur de la planète c'est le
devenir de l'humanité
c'est une page blanche où on peut
explorer de nouveaux futurs une
coopération internationale très large et
une gouvernance mondiale une meilleure
façon de gérer ses ressources
je disais banc d'essai terrain de jeu
moi cette image pour vous expliquer un
petit peu comment ça peut se construire
un village binaire ça doit se construire
de façon très progressive c'est un
projet composites ou bien sûr il y aura
de multiples utilisateurs avec des
intérêts très différents avec des
expertises variées complémentaires avec
des ressources diverses des usages qui
seront multiples avec des participants
du monde entier participants du monde
entier qui seront heureux de cohabiter
qui vont développer cet esprit village
alors je vous épargne l'amitié des
peuples bien que je sois très fier
d'avoir passé 10 ans de ma vie en russie
et d'avoir été décorés de l'amitié des
peuples
un village si un endroit où il ya des
infrastructures et des biens communs qui
sont mis à la disposition de chacun
un village ça peut être aussi s'étendre
en outre chacun peut réaliser son projet
dont avec toute la liberté dans le
respect bien sûr de celui des autres à
vous allez me dire utopie non pas du
tout les agences spatiales aujourd'hui
sont déjà en train de construire les
socles le socle et les briques de ce
village il ya beaucoup de missions qui
sont sur le pâtis raw prête à être
développé pour renvoyer vers la lune des
orbiteurs des lander des rovers
j'ai choisi de vous montrer des vraies
images c'est pas des images de synthèse
c'était vrai images prises sur la lune
et j'ai pris l'exemple de la mission
chang'e 3 c'est une mission chinoise en
décembre 2013 et elle met en scène deux
personnages très connus de la cosmogonie
chinoise change la déesse de la lune qui
a toujours un compagnon avec elle qui
est le lapin de jade
alors là vous avez deux photos qui
mettent en présence ce couple cette
première photo une vraie photo qui nous
a été envoyé de la lune et bien c'est le
lander d'atterrissage songe qui
photographient le petit rover que vous
voyez au fond c'est le rover you to you
to ses lapins de jade en chinois
et puis la faute au réveil ce seuil où
tout cette fois ci le tireur qui a pris
en photographie sa sont porteuses sa
matrice change 3 avec le le trajet qui
lui conduit ça ce sont pour les
initiatives publiques institutionnels et
vous étaient tous entendu parler des
initiatives privées aujourd'hui dans ce
champ de la conquête de l'espace ont dû
parler de spe 6 vous avez entendu parler
des lots de masques peut-être entendu
parler en début de semaine tout juste
moon express qui souhaitent poser une
charge utile sur la lune en 2010
c'est tous entendu parler des challenges
google le google lunar x prize
il s'agit mais d'un rover sur la lune
et qu'ils fassent 500 m de déplacement
c'est prévu pour 2017
il ya 30 millions de dollars à la clé
c'est un petit peu tard pour vous pour
participer mais il ya plein d'autres
challenge et technologiques qui sont
proposés par l' agence spatiale
européenne par la nasa pour de la
robotique à destination les nerfs alors
est ce que nous saurons être les
bâtisseurs du 21e siècle
oui nous sommes prêts les sondes
automatiques elles vont nous aider à
choisir le très bon lieux d'alunissage
le pôle sud le pôle nord et ya encore
des discussions
un endroit qui soit suffisamment
ensoleillée pour qu'on puisse y avoir de
l'énergie pour développer la la mission
un endroit où il ya de l'eau pour
extraire de l'hydrogène et de l'oxygène
et puis un endroit où le terrain soit
pas trop accidenté de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent déployer les opérations des
robots précurseur parce que les robots
et robots aujourd'hui ils sont en
capacité d'installer cette
infrastructure permanente sur la lune en
serbo ils peuvent être autonomes ils
peuvent être telle opération il sole
depuis leur
regardez ce que vous allez voir c'est un
robot collector de la poussière lunaire
le régolithe cette poussière alimente
ensuite une imprimante 3d qui va
permettre de commencer à construire et à
protéger ces habitats
si un petit peu l'oppidum des villages
gaulois c'est le tout début
le noyau initial qui va être habité par
des équipages que j'aime appeler nos
ancêtres de demain
alors qui sont ces villageois ces
villageois cd oms et des femmes de
toutes nationalités son exclusion c'est
des ingénieurs et des médecins c'est des
pilotes c'est dès le maire de la ville
sans doute n'est-ce pas et ce sont des
organisateurs coordonnateur des réseaux
de distribution des réseaux de transport
et bien d'autres choses encore alors
j'en suis presque sûr certains et
certaines dans la salle aurait
envie et pourrait rejoindre un projet
comme celui-ci je me trompe il y en a
dans la salle et on qu'est ce qu'il y de
quoi ils ont besoin
ces villageois ils ont besoin d'eau ils
ont besoin d'électricité ils ont besoin
des écosystèmes clos fermé pour leur
permettre de l'abordable la nourriture
ils ont besoin de matériaux de
construction ils ont besoin de système
de déplacement
ça c'est bien matériel environ deux ans
et puis bien évidemment ils ont besoin
de ces biens immatériels de la musique
sans doute alors je sais pas si david
andrew et linda iran les rejoindre bon
de toute forme de culture qu'on peut
envisager dans ce village dans ce
village qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
ses habitants alors ils vont faire de la
science il ya des sciences de la lune
mieux comprendre la lune on connaît pas
encore très bien
les sciences depuis la lune imaginez cet
observatoire sur la face cachée de la
lune
débarrassé de toute pollution et que
tout me permet d'explorer beaucoup plus
librement
l'univers et puis assez science des
environnements hostiles à la survie de
l'homme
ça peut nous être utile sur terme c'est
parce que la nuit en trois heures puis
c'est utile aussi à l'exploration plus
lointaines ils vont vers la science ils
vont inventer des développements
technologiques on a vu par exemple
l'impression 3d des nouveaux matériaux
de construction ils vont développer des
véhicules de tous types
ils vont je l'espère protéger contre la
poussière lunaire poussière lunaire
c'est un problème très important
protéger contre les radiations commencé
à explorer les forages parce qu'ils vont
y faire du commerce et des affaires et
aux bras des systèmes de distribution de
communication il y aura l'exploitation
minière chaussures que vous en avez
entendu parler on
parlé récemment et puis il y aura des
offres de tourisme c'est un village où
on habite
et on vit alors quelles sont les étapes
où les étapes et calendrier à une
première étape c'est de réunir ce
consortium qui permettra d'avoir les
moyens technologiques pour avancer pour
en faire concrètement un projet est
réalisable
ce consortium
c'est faisable tout à fait ce consortium
il faudra lui donner une gouvernance
suffisamment fluide pour respecter
liberté et projets ça c'est vrai que
c'est un challenge faudra bien sûr aussi
trouver les ressources budgétaires alors
de tous types bien évidemment public
également de l'entreprenariat privé et
de tous types pourquoi pas la vôtre et
au delà une validation politique
validation politique je l'espère dans
les deux à trois ans qui viennent parce
que pour moi je garde en tête que 2019
et bien c'est le 50e anniversaire du
premier pas de l'homme sur la lune ce
projet c'est une mission vous la
compresser pas une mission spatiale
comme les autres c'est pas une mission
scientifique et technique même si les
objectifs scientifiques sont absolument
majeur est tout à fait fascinant
si un projet global sociaux économiques
et culturels
c'est pas simplement une affaire d'
agences spatiales
vous l'avez vu c'est du public c'est du
privé c'est de l'engagement de
l'adhésion citoyenne c'est pas du tout
impossible de concevoir ses
participations internationales très
large bien au delà des 5 nations qui
aujourd'hui constituent les partenaires
de la station spatiale internationale
les chinois les russes les américains
vont pouvoir y travailler et l'europe et
cette ambition européenne que je porte
elle est attendue comme initiative du
projet et elle est reconnue parce que
nous avons cette capacité à travailler
avec chacun et puis c'est pas un projet
qui coûte ces centaines de milliards de
dollars et d'euros
comme on le met souvent en avant on sait
aujourd'hui qu'un projet de ce type qui
va se développer sur des dizaines
d'années avec les projets technologiques
actuels ça sera un budget d'un ordre de
grandeur inférieur pour vous mettre un
petit peu le schéma le budget de
l'agencé spatiale européenne aujourd'hui
pour développer toutes ses missions sur
une année ça représente 2 places de
cinéma d'un citoyen européen n'auriez
pas envie de payer deux séances de
cinéma pour assister à la projection
pour contribuer au scénario et peut-être
même pour jouer un rôle
ce projet en plus il est vraiment pas
inutile dans une société comme la nôtre
qui est une société en crise crise
économique en crise sociale qui un ponte
déficit devenir moi je dis il faut
penser l'avenir
un projet comme ça c'est un
investissement d'avenir ça va nous
permettre de préserver notre présent à
la surface de la terre
pas simplement préserver la planète mais
penser à notre humanité
l'humain face au changement climatique
l'humain face à la gestion durable des
ressources l'humain dans la transition
des moyens énergétiques un projet comme
ça c'est un projet qui va mobiliser
toute notre créativité penser autrement
c'est un projet qui va développer nos
intelligences scientifique technique je
sais à quel point les jeunes ingénieurs
peuvent être passionné par des projets
de ce type c'est une aventure collective
c'est vrai que ça met au défi notre
humanité
mais c'est aussi une aventure qui va
nous permettre d'aller plus loin d'aller
explorer plus loin et bien sûr mars
ça en fait partie c'est
votre aventure c'est notre aventure
commune
façonner l'avenir c'est un travail
collectif qui prend ses racines dans nos
désirs dans nos rêves dans nos visions
en ce qui me concerne j je trouve ça
sera encore formidable de pousser la
vision plus loin sa famille très
personnel j'imagine un programme
spécifique erasmus mundus village non
sur le sol européen ou votre génération
dans les écoles dans les universités
dans les entreprises vous pourrez
contribuer activement puis vous pourrez
accueillir les gens du monde entier
et puis quitte à y aller moi je vous
propose qui est une mobilisation pour
porter la candidature du village une
aire à l'exposition universelle en 2030
voilà seize minutes 19 minutes non c'est
pas assez
pas suffisant pour délimiter rêve d'une
telle intensité
ce que je vous donne là c'est simplement
un matériau de construction
maintenant c'est à vous ayez le l'audace
de saisir cette chance
prenez la liberté de transformer mon
rêve en votre réalité
j'attends vos idées on en parlera plus
tard rejoignez nous rêver explorer
imaginez surmonter les obstacles
découvrir ses limites repousser les
limites ce qui fait de nous des êtres
humains
soyons visionnaire ensemble et dénoue à
construire votre village